en politique il y a ceux qui restent
dans l'ombre du leader et ceux qui
savent se placer à ses côtés pour
défendre leurs idéaux contre les
injustices pour qu'il y ait plus de
fraternité de solidarité notre ville
elle aura épauler jean pierre
chevènement toute sa carrière lui
qu'elle rencontra en 72 après une
première vie comme salariés d'alstom la
belfortaine sera sa suppléante et
démissionnera par deux fois pour lui
céder sa place de député
c'est justement comme député que la
france la découvre en 89
après le dramatique incendie criminel de
belfort qui fait 15 morts gilberte marin
moskowitz propose une loi sécurité je
pense que pour l'automne au plus tard
la loi devrait clarifier les choses et
imposer des règles à l'ensemble des
français
très engagée dans les droits des femmes
l'éducation ou encore l'adoption
elle participera également aux
manifestations de soutien aux salariés
d'alstom en 2000 plus la mobilisation
sera forte plus ça fera reculer
les décideurs qui n'en ont rien à faire
des sommes très fatigués par la maladie
ces dernières années gilberte marin
moscovite s'est éteinte ce 26 juin à
l'âge de 82 ans jean pierre chevènement
a été un des premiers à saluer sa
mémoire